i'm so excited to talk to you about this
show this show is phenomenal epic is
obviously going to be the word that
everyone's throwing around for this but
i want to know from the two of you
at what moment when you're out there on
horseback or out there with
the whole wilderness in front of you are
you thinking to yourself knowing to
yourself that this is something that's
really going to hit with people that's
really going to resonate
um
i
i personally
don't think about that i
i feel like we have to be
we all are so present in in the moment
while we're filming and also well you
have to be for multiple reasons because
we need to be
that's our job
um but also
uh
could get injured i mean because the
things that we are doing um they are
real and um
we're in character we're we're in these
remarkable
places that we get we've gotten to film
um even though they've at the uh
you know it's been too cold been too
windy been too hot
despite all of that
i think for us what it has done it has
shown that uh
the journey
that uh the pioneers made
the across the country from east to west
uh wow i have a whole new respect yes
for what they went through honestly so i
i feel like all of us would probably say
that
we're in the moment completely when you
have to be 100 we're still shooting
currently so i think we're we're stuck
in in that mindset right now so to even
think about people watching this a week
from now it's the strangest thing
imagine it yeah i'm excited though
i really haven't thought about it that
much yeah
i just got finished speaking with tim
and he had said that if he was out there
back in the day he'd last maybe a week
before he's turned to your faith and
said this i'm good with settling here
wherever we're at right now do you do
you think that that is an accurate uh
representation of what he would be like
back then oh hell no
wait he said he would last for a week
yes i would last for a week that that he
himself would last for a week
uh i i think he would last longer he was
being he was being humble
yeah he would last he would yeah he said
he's tough he's a tough guy he would he
would not let that uh
he would do it even despite nature he he
would do that but
look it's it
there are things that happened on the
trail um i have to say
i i don't really know that i could name
them i don't know if it's appropriate to
do so but
um
i
the way that people lost their lives
while on the trail the top i don't know
five to seven
um i was shocked
at
some of the ways that that people lost
their lives it was not what
not how i thought uh
it was a dangerous time and and imagine
it's i think it's difficult
for us to imagine this day and time
going on an adventure or or seeking a
place that you know absolutely nothing
about and you really do not know there's
no gps there's no map
you really do not know the territory to
which you are headed
um and i think that that is played out
and written very well
um in this show and it's depicted in
incredibly well and this you know
isabelle
uh her character is just wow i i told
her this before we started filming i
think it was the week before we started
filming or either cowboy camp i can't it
was but it was before
yeah we were at a hotel room and
i just i was like my god to have this
type of uh role written uh for her uh
it's just extraordinary it's a beautiful
story and it would set strength and
and purpose and freedom that all the
things that that
a young woman at her age should
experience that most people don't have
the opportunity to do these days
yeah there's there's a part of the first
episode that i love is about and it's
your narration over watching
uh your mom on horseback and basically
you know i'm paraphrasing paraphrasing
but saying like i didn't see
my mother i saw this badass woman i saw
this incredibly strong woman in that
moment
is that what it was been like and what
it has been like working alongside faith
uh in this project oh that's how i felt
about her from the minute i met her i
was i mean she is
this woman has resolve she has guts
wit
she and i
the thing that really captivated me
though was her sense of humor
she's the goofiest person i've ever met
in my life
and i love it i love it and she can make
every animal sound that you could
possibly imagine
it's amazing but it's not something you
don't know what to expect when you meet
anyone you know and she's just
oh she's incredible all right i'm not
gonna look at my
do we get a hint of that particular
skill
somewhere down the line on uh in the
first season
the animal sounds i mean
i don't think so i really hope not that
would you because yeah i think that
would take the audience
that could be disturbing
so what i was curious about is you know
i was asking tim about the idea of when
you're at the end of a shoot day and
you've gone through all of what you've
gone through
um
do you reflect on the day and say to
each other like that scene was intense
i'm impressed with the the work that you
did because
the intention right is to
i guess kind of surprise each other on
the day you're not working on it
together you're working on it separately
before you get on set right
uh-huh that's correct uh-huh uh usually
i'm at uh with tim and me yes yeah
yeah
i think at the end of the day we would
all
uh say uh
don't talk to me i'm too tired this is
what i'm going to feel
that is so true
don't even touch me or look at me
um uh
yeah i i've le look tim is an incredible
actor and he
is
extraordinary in in this series honestly
um he's a natural horseman and he does
a lot of amazing things on horseback and
it's it's fun to watch him
do those things obviously i i know him
very very well
but he surprised me you know throughout
this
this um working through this series uh
but
at the end of the day it's usually uh
what are we gonna eat
it's time to go to bed and what's your
call time
what time do you have to get up in the
morning yeah
it's about how do you get yourself like
physically and mentally prepared
for going into
uh into the shoot like after some time
off knowing what you did
uh just before that how difficult it
would have been to be out there
physically and mentally i'm sure
um
uh you just walk on set
and you are wearing
the period clothing and you're sweating
i felt sweat going down my legs i've
never experienced that before you're in
105 degree weather and then you're in 12
degree weather and
so i think
just all i have to do is be present and
it doesn't take much
really to step into that character's
shoes
and also a good sad
depressing song
always helps me
sink into it yeah really yeah have a
couple of those too
in my ears well and also just the the
scenery um
made me so emotional i would just look
around and want to cry for some reason
it's so stunning
yeah
well the show is stunning it's a good
word for it too uh congratulations on it
looking forward to more
thank you for speaking with us